donc voilà la star acade c'est fini on
le sait c'est Oscar Sisto vous savez le
SCAR Sisto et ben regardez il était chez
notre ami Jordan Deluxe qui a tout le
monde regardez ce qu'il a déclaré il
tape un peu
c'est presque un soulagement de tourner
la page vraiment c'est un soulagement
c'est presque un soulagement vous pouvez
capter parce que je dis comment je parle
c'est presque soulagement de ne plus
être le problème c'est waouh c'est c'est
du bien ça peut faire du bien pour
quelle raison après tant d'années
d'absence comme ça il y a une sorte de
fantasmes qui est très lourd
c'est-à-dire qu'on restera toujours
Amélie Poulain et toujours bien sûr
c'est ça
remplace ça Kamel Ouali personne
remplacera Oscar Sisto ça vient pas à
remplacer ça continue c'est une chaîne
c'est le cycle
[Applaudissements]
totalement pas d'accord avec lui parce
que je trouve que Adeline Antoniotti par
exemple où Yanis Marchal etc ont très
bien remplacé les enfants
de la star acade cette année de théâtre
moi ma fille par exemple à 15 ans elle
connaît ceux de maintenant et moi je
connais ceux d'avant donc toi tu les
connais pas c'est parce que tu fais
partie de ma génération mais les
nouveaux ils sont connus par les jeunes
pas par nous tu vois ce que je veux dire
réfléchissez ça chez vous
oui non mais en fait si je peux me
permettre c'est pas du tout ce qu'il
voulait dire ce qu'il voulait rappeler
c'était lui il est pas le seul à avoir
dit Kamel Ouali Raphaël Ricci Armand
Altay en fait on avait oublié les
téléspectateurs ont oublié que c'était
des artistes à part entière
des chorégraphes des d'accord etc et que
ils ont été étiquetés à ça et ça les a
gonflé ils en pouvaient plus et quand ça
s'est arrêté certains après que
reprendre leur vie en main et je leur en
veux pas mais je reconnais que prof de
théâtre c'est horrible c'est comme prof
de tennis je vous embrasse tous les
profs de tennis mais c'est sûr que tu te
dis jamais quand je serai vieux mon rêve
c'est l'épreuve de tennis ton rêve c'est
des joueurs à l'ATP ça raté une marche
de tennis mais c'est des métiers où
c'est compliqué de dire que tu voulais
vraiment être prof de tennis prof de
théâtre j'ai du mal à croire que tu
voulais être totalement dans l'ombre
m'expliquer aux autres comment réussir
mais après c'est oui
qui sont souvent pauvres
animateurs non pas du maître menteuse
pour le petit spectateurs j'ai pas un
couteau dans le dos non j'ai pas je sens
que toi si je glisse mais tu piétines
mais moi je pense que
sera le premier qui me trahira bon il
avait dit que ce serait moi il a raison
mais je pense que ça sera toi moi non
moi j'ai ma petite sœur non je pensais
que moi là pour les profs de tâte comme
tu dis les profs de théâtre raté ils
auraient rêvé d'être comédiens mais ils
sont prof de théâtre là star academ ça a
quand même été un très gros coup de
projecteur pour eux pour la suite tout
le monde voulait prendre des cours avec
eux
derrière exactement
de concerts plus qu'avant faut pas
cracher non plus dans la alors il a
sorti une phrase comme ça c'est possible
sur la guerre aux jeunisme regardez on
va trouver logique qu'on garde la même
château on garde le même présentateur on
garde les mêmes profs vous êtes d'accord
avec moi il y a pas de logique les
époques changent la jeunesse change
après le problème c'est qu'il y a un
génisme poussé alors que les gens qui
nous aiment aujourd'hui ils ont 35 ans
avec des enfants de 15 ans donc c'est
plusieurs générations dire quoi vous
étiez trop vieux pour
pas si vous dites jeunisme
on pense que le public a 17 ans en
moyenne alors que il a 35 50 le public
il est il est les gens regardent cette
émission en famille donc il faut pas
chercher un spectacle pour les jeunes
c'est un spectacle pour la famille la
richesse de la star c'était ça je crois
que Pedro dans cet extrait c'est que
Jordanie complètement débile et il voit
qu'il comprend pas ce qu'il lui dit on
pense que le public que tu imprimes
quand on te parle voilà
c'est ça tu lui dis c'est presque un
soulagement qu'est-ce que je viens de
dire presque comme ça
il avait dit qu'il avait envie de
revenir
alors après on va encore dire que
j'appelle tout ça mais les gens qui font
de l'antenne pour expliquer qu'ils
veulent plus faire de l'antenne ça me
fait toujours rire
d'avant et la nouvelle émission donc
c'est ce de avant qui viennent critiquer
la nouvelle mais en fait c'est parce
qu'ils ont juste pas été rappelé autre
chose assez hallucinant qui s'est passé
cette semaine c'était donc de matinale
de Guillaume Genton Jean-Pascal Lacoste
a déclaré que dans la Star Ac 1 Armanda
était tombé amoureux de lui qu'il
s'était fait des petits bisous hors
caméra et que aujourd'hui encore si elle
n'a pas elle n'a pas voulu faire la
nouvelle saison c'est parce qu'elle a
encore des sentiments pour lui
il a dit en gros
comme m'a dit
Jean pas partie du corps professionnel
elle a voulu être en raccord avec maman
de toujours voilà et dire bon bah
puisqu'il n'y va pas moi non plus je ne
veux plus faire partie de l'académie
mais c'est quand même deux choses un ça
veut quand même dire si c'est vrai qu'il
y ait le conflit d'intérêt parce qu'à la
base
qui disait qu'il va être qui va être
nommé et puis la deuxième chose c'est
que j'espère que la demander parce que
qu'elle bouge à tri de dire à une femme
qui devait avoir une soixantaine
d'années à l'époque sortir tout d'un
coup 20 ans après je sortais avec c'est
quoi cette histoire
c'est faux et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que j'en passe à faire il est très très
beau gosse et en plus et alors si elle
l'aime et si si imaginer ils ont une
petite amourette et tout c'est quoi le
problème
moi je pense qu'elle est pas au courant
par contre ce dont je me souviens très
bien c'est qu'à l'époque elle était la
prof qui prenait le plus sa défense
quand il avait ses colères que parfois
il dépasse les bords etc
arrondi c'est les angles essayer de
valoriser son côté
ça aurait pu choquer des gens devant la
voir soixantaine d'années à l'époque et
il en avait 22 23 ça aurait pu quand
c'est la femme
quand c'est l'inverse ça choque personne
aujourd'hui
des médias elle était très belle amandaï
c'était toujours c'est parce que je veux
dire alors Elisabelle non alors moi ce
qui me choque c'est que toute la presse
a repris mais alors vraiment sans Mousta
sans vérifier mais oui mais c'est quand
même d'abord non je crois qu'après il a
il a pas vaguement démenti il a pas dit
que c'était une blague
ouais mais c'est pas obligé de reprendre
parce que si les goujat tous ceux qui
ont repris le sang aussi
entre ça et la semaine dernière elle
nous a dit allez regarder France 3
pendant l'émission
vous êtes sûr qu'il n'a pas démenti je
connais pas après toute la vie
et n'oublie pas quand tu prends la
parole pour moi
je trouve ça oui il était pas avec
Jennifer
tout le château
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]